entre aplausos y cantos así fue la
recepción del presidente electo de
Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva en la
con 27 el izquierdista pronunció un
discurso en el que dejó algo claro
Brasil está de vuelta en la escena
internacional Un regreso en el que según
Lula se luchará contra el cambio
climático y las desigualdades a nivel
mundial y del que cobrará la deuda
pendiente de los países desarrollados
con los países más vulnerables 100 mil
millones de dólares que aseguró aún no
se han pagado
tengo que salir de pateo los acuerdos
Tienen que salir del papel y para eso es
imprescindible volver disponibles los
recursos para que los más pobres puedan
enfrentar las consecuencias de los
problemas creados en buena medida por
los países más ricos de una manera
desproporcionada que está afectando a
los más vulnerables
en la con 27 Lula mostró su voluntad de
desmarcarse de su predecesor Yair
bolsonaro y reactivar los esfuerzos por
luchar contra la deforestación que llegó
a máximos en los últimos 15 años durante
el mandato del ultraderechista
no hay seguridad climática para el mundo
sino una amazonía protegida
del resultado de las elecciones
brasileñas dependía no solo la paz y el
bienestar del pueblo brasileño sino
también la supervivencia de la amazonía
y por lo tanto la supervivencia de
nuestro planeta
la creación de una cumbre de los países
amazónicos fue uno de los primeros
anuncios a nivel internacional que hizo
Lula desde su elección en octubre al
mismo tiempo esbozó varias líneas que
seguirá durante su mandato
luchar contra los crímenes ambientales y
crear un Ministerio de los pueblos
originarios